hey guys i'm ryan right I'm Samantha
Ashley fell today we're gonna check out
from The Tonight Show Starring Jimmy
Fallon the kid theater with Channing
Tatum okay here we go here we go here we
go
y'all ready for this not a challenge
it's more of a fun thing so we're having
a fun challenge it's a fun challenge
but here's the catch I love celebrities
then you'll be doing that we're reading
or not from the actual movie they were
all written by elementary school kids
just the title we asked them to write
scenes based on what they think the
movie called
[Music]
all right they didn't serious this is
for you this first one is from Steven
he's 8 years old from Dallas Texas
chanting you'll be playing the role of
Magic Mike and I'll be playing the role
of Josh Higgins you'll you'll read scene
description for example
all right Higgins set the scene Josh's
bike has a flat tire he needs help
oh no my bike is a flat tire how am I
gonna get to hockey practice on time oh
I know I know what I'll do Magic Mike
yes and Magic Man
I'm like regular Mike
[Applause]
[Music]
can you help fix my bike tire it's all
out of there yes I can because I'm magic
I'm like regular Mike it's sentimental
yeah you said that
just fix my bike okay
[Music]
where's your bike right here using my
magic
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Thank You Magic Mike wait a second
well what's so magic about a regular
bike huh oh yeah
you're right I guess I'm just Mike
[Applause]
[Music]
oh this one pinin by Asher
he is 6 years old from Greensburg
Pennsylvania six year old Chanyeol
what's gonna be playing Magic Mike I'll
be playing the role of boss
Higgins one set the scene boss is on the
phone thank you is all on the phone Mike
you need to come into my office please
[Music]
okay
but her that you've not been doing that
good of a job yeah I'm sorry I know but
you need to try hard so can I please
have another chance to keep an alien's
out of this plan please yes but this is
your last chance because you are Magic
Mike I'm sorry but you are fired because
you let aliens come to earth again
do you know why I let aliens invade this
planet colder no my takes office human
mask
[Music]
Magic Mike is taking is really wrote
this because it seems like I'm not
spending eight year old writings play
the role of Magic Bird Magic Mike scenes
Magic Bird thank you thank you Higgins
hey mezack burt what's wrong
I don't like be in a mess bird
makes me calm you down here on your
forehead
[Applause]
magic my clothes on magic Birds favor
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
magic magic where there's a homoerotic
[Music]
what will calm me down oh well I like to
sing I know let's sing this song
together please oh please
ok let's sing our famous song Mexican
bird come fly away with me
he had it already sing together
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow that was awesome that was really
awesome oh they made some children's
writing for you very very homoerotic
which dirty I guess it's not wrong or
anything unless it's real my Catholic
school boys then then there's some
serious concerns that those nuns should
be having but if it's like a public
school kid totally makes sense
totally makes sense all of that is so
wrong is it yeah comment below know this
really did seem like eight-year-old kids
wrote this though like I was hearing it
like damn that sounds pretty authentic
actually yeah it seemed like any ear old
kids mind of course and I'm sure you
know when they hear Magic Mike they
literally think of a man named Mike who
is magical you know we'll be [ __ ] up
if these kids wrote because they wrote
this script off of just the title what
if they then saw the movie don't you you
want to see the movie I know but let's
say they like were like wow now I want
to actually watch it and mom and dad
won't let them watch it then they see
it's about male strippers their world
will come crashing down I'm also kind of
a little worried that that might happen
yeah because they're gonna get excited
that their stories are being read and
they're gonna be like well what's is
Magic Mike thing about yeah and then
they're gonna watch it and then they're
gonna aspire to be male strippers like
you um
it's not an aspiration I have greatly
succeeded that is my part-time income
and it takes care of all my bills
I ain't knocking it yeah you're
definitely not knocking it doesn't even
mean
I don't know those perverted stones
alright anyway guys thanks for tuning in
to the channel if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects could check out some Mantha
Ashley felt channel she is on a channel
on YouTube I am you should check it out
you get boss on Facebook Instagram
Twitter and vine where if we get enough
followers we can get even
or product placement meaning so much
more money money is just everything for
things like coaster coasters are great
they you can put cups on there you can
block out your someone's vision with it
and you know it's really hot if you're
like doing a girl like really hard like
you're on top of her in between her
right and then you're like doing her
really hard and she might be making too
much noise when you're inside her so
then you just take a placemat just put
it in your mouth
shut up no she might be into it don't
tell me you're not into that we're not
having this kind of a kind of girly
we're not we're not how I know you you
like a coaster being in your mouth what
a coaster their mouth well why do you
put so many things in your mouth
sometimes what are the same thing thanks
for watching guys